[Music]
opens his mouth
and he sings you know him
you understand him you feel him and
that's just a very particular gift
[Music]
as far as elvis girls it wasn't just
about making music it was about singing
from your soul and singing something
that needed to be sung well that's all
right
elvis is vocally always really dexterous
and always pushing himself and exploring
so that we had to do interpretations of
and austin sings all the live
performance young elves he sings himself
all the movement all in that and then
the latter stuff is a blend between
austin's voice and real elves
we went to nashville and memphis and we
recorded an rca where elvis recorded
it's my first time ever in a recording
studio i felt such a massive amount of
fear but the thing that i sort of rested
in was that elvis talks so much about
his own fear his own stage fright i mean
that was one of the main reasons why he
started moving in the first place was
just all this energy inside and how it
came out
[Music]
one thing that i was just loving was
music he was someone i believe was about
bringing people together and i think the
story itself is profoundly meshed in
american culture
our bodies just feel this energy it was
so much fun to do and so liberating and
exciting the music that i want music
that i love
music that makes me happy
[Music]